ضموا الينا من اديمان مراسله الجزيره سلام
خضر سلام كيف تبدو المعطيات والاخبار
اليوم
سلمى نبدا من الجانب الانساني عمليات
مسانده العائلات التي تعيش في الخيم التي
انشاتها السلطات التركيه ومنظمه الغي
اغاثه تستمر في اليمن كما في بقيه المدن
المنكوبه لكن ما يجري حاليا في تلك المدن
كما هنا في الديامان خاصه في المناطق التي
حصل فيها ضرر كبير وزاره العد التركيه
اكدت انها ارسلت قرابه 600 فريق ميداني
مهمه هذه الفرق هي رفع عينات من جميع
المباني المنهاره بشكل كامل قبل ازاله
الانقاض الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
كان قد خال امس ان عمليه رفع الانقاض
بالكامل وهدم المباني المتضرره بشكل كبير
والتي تحتاج الى ازاله عاجله ستنتهي
بنهايه هذا الشهر بالتزامن مع هذا تعمل
وزاره العدل لا يتم السماح برفع انقاذ اي
مبنى منهار بشكل كامل او اي هدمه او هدم
اي مبنى يحتاج الى هدم قبل اخذ عينات من
هذه المباني الغرض من ذلك هو اكمال ما
بداته وزاره العدل التركيه من اجراء
تحقيقات عن سبب ارتفاع اعداد الابنيه التي
انهارت بشكل كامل هنا في اديمان على سبيل
المثال قرابه 2600 مبنى سقطت بالكامل
تحولت الى حطام وقتلت تحتها اكثر من
3700 شخص التحقيقات التجري حوله مدى
التزام المتعهدين بسلامه البناء وبمعايير
البناء المقاومه للزلزال قرابه 95% من
المباني التي انهارت قالت السلطات التركيه
انها تمت او تم بناء هذه الابنيه قبل
العام 2000 ولكن هناك ابنيه بنيت بعد ذلك
العام وتعرضت لاضرار او انهارت ايضا تلك
يتم
التحقيق حولها خاصه ان شاهدنا سلمى بعض
المباني في عدد من المدن التي مررنا بها
شخصيا مررت اكثر من سته من المدن المنكوبه
هناك بعض الابنيه لم تحصل فيها اي اضرار
هي فقط وقعت بمعنى بفعل الهزه او الحركه
التكتونيه وقعت هذه
البنايه ولم تتضرر جميع من كان بداخلها
بقي على قيد الحياه لكن
والهيكل البناء لم يتضرر بعد الخبراء
يقولون انها قد تكون مقاومه للزلزال على
سبيل المثال ولكن عنف الحركه التكتونيه
التي شهدتها تركيا بزلزال كهرمان مراش
والزلزال الذي تلاه زلزلين متتاليين ادت
الى هذه النتيجه هذا المبنى على سبيل
المثال سيحتاج الى عمليه ازاله سريعه جدا
كان هناك فريق قبل قليل هنا في المكان وتم
رفع عينه من هذه الانقاض من من المبنى غير
المنهار وشوارع اديمان سلمى باتت يعني
تزدحم بالاليات الثقيله هذه الاليات يتركز
عملها على ازاله هذه الانقاذ لسرعه اتمام
هذه العمليه وبالتالي الانتقال الى عمليه
او المرحله الثانيه وهي التي ستبدا بحسب
الرئيس التركي مع بدايه الشهر المقبل
اعاده بناء الابنيه التي تضررت وتدعيم تلك
التي لا تزال قابله للسكن لكنها تحتاج
عمليات اعمار بسيطه او تدعيم بسيطه سلمى
شكرا لك يا سلام خضر مراسلتنا من اليمن